and thank god the director because you  know the sides were i was trying to buy  pills from tariq my roommate at the  school choke but it was one scene and  i'm like hey let me let me buy pills and  it was just an [ __ ] wearing sperry's  this and that what are sperry's it's  like boat shoes it's like what every  rich [ __ ] from nantucket wears you  know what i mean are those those  actually in fact yeah these are  old spirits  but those are the sneakers these are  secret they're not like boats they're  not the best  oh i know what you're talking about no  laces yeah it's right right it's  terrible right so  i'm gonna say i'm wearing parries but no  the s just kind of came off the bottom  yeah no those are cool those are  sneakers yeah those are all right i like  those